foreign
Victor is with it that was Victor no it
wasn't I tried to give Victor a minute
ago and I screwed it up or Victor
screwed it up or who just who screwed it
up Victor you or me
I have no idea
how can we help you but I'll take the
blank that's okay sometimes I hit the
wrong button I've been doing this a
while but I do it sometimes what's up
hey nothing much um so I'm in the
process of selling my house right now
and um I'm not sure exactly how much I'm
getting back but I was just trying to
see is with the money that I do get back
it might be 30 30 000 might be a little
bit more
um because we still own the house so um
I was just trying to see what the money
that I get what should I do should I
save it did I pay off some of my debt or
where are you gonna live
uh I'm actually moving in with my sister
for now
until I figure out a situation uh I
don't think buying a house right now is
the best best idea
so you know because the situation in
your life
uh yeah okay yeah all right
so for right now you're just kind of uh
reaching for some safety
yes how much debt do you have sir
so I owe 26 on my car
and um if I sell the house that would
take good get off the house so 26 on my
car and maybe like 900 credit card debt
what do you make
uh 55 000 a year
there's a theme Here Ken yes yes
yeah you know what I'm gonna say then
what am I gonna say
the car the car
sell the car
yeah I would go buy a 10 000 car with
cash and I would sell this other one and
again you're trying to reach you're
moving you're selling your home you're
moving in with your sister because of
Life situation and you need a sense of
safety right now and just exactly like
the last caller this car is stealing
your safety